louder with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter and hopper
so Louie knows
donde esta max kawar nosotros somos
mahkum no lost Mary CONUS YouTube heroes
[Music]
last I left you black Oh mugs Gabbar was
pumping mugs under the YouTube radar in
record time and the elites in Silicon
Valley were starting to notice but like
any success tale triumph always comes
with its own whole new set of hiccups
okay que esto
Caputo's maras esto que dicen que soy
Ben Shapiro hmm ven ven the endo bosses
con cancer in Sun Prairie toe we respond
oh man it's approaches it's mclubbe
superior little sis here exclusive the
mo Club you have 3 million subscribers
don't even stand on me don't insist a
stranger you're our witness
Delia got a scone - no - no -
- donde esta let me know Oh
then they black of their dad no your
Louis C Z or ass that boom or hmm arrow
Vox it's about to feel stupid or the
story that was being told about a bear
cover its wife
Cena has failed that's losing resist
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
have my crumbs you got Mike this is now
at Bill's this is I'll give you some of
my crumpet is genocide denying we have
Nigel Farage on the show today yes Faraj
or Farage I'm not entirely sure mr.
brexit of course this it couldn't be
more timely because I've no idea what
else going on not a clue
we're talking about the abortion laws
going on in New York
soon-to-be Rhode Island and Virginia
everyone's abortion crazy which makes
raises the question today before we
bring everyone in considering the recent
kind of abortion bills that have been in
the news I don't want to know whether
you're pro-life or probe or ssin but
where do you think this argument is
actually really taking place policy wise
you think about a woman's right to
choose do you think the legislation
actually revolves around when the
termination occurs or do you think the
left just wants to kill babies up until
birth period and the Conservatives are
just as extreme on the other side answer
below I really want to know yeah yes a
reasonable question ask now we have
Brautigan in third chair we have quarter
black caret what's that my board I
wanted it one of the day with me oh yeah
with the cheapest just about cheapest
wine you get it's barefoot that's got a
nice screw top it's your long journey
line by the way there's gonna be one and
a quarter black is here and I almost
want to refuse with that crap over there
we have duck horn the decison duck horn
the discussion discussion come on can
fight maybe you can discuss the horrible
decisions that probably made with
barefoot I'll actually let people drink
this later you're gonna bring yours home
that's true straight it's true this my
never leaves the wine now I'm doing them
a favor by letting them drink your crap
your swill you're letting your doing us
a favor yes by poisoning us
you couldn't appreciate leaving us with
the guy on the other end of the CB radio
from Joyride like a good rain and washes
everything clean barefoot all right so
there is a been a bombshell development
in Russian news a lot of people don't
know this huge this 1980 footage of a
shirtless Bernie Sanders who was
drunkenly singing with commies it's real
it's real
[Music]
[Applause]
serious serious
[Applause]
by the way does anybody leave for a
second that he hasn't smoked pot and
when I was the cameras there I do I
never partake I don't think someone
should be arrested for plant I'm like oh
that was what got me most impacted that
speech but here's these videos have been
leaked in Oppo research like this
actually regularly gets leaked to the
press
yeah which is unfortunate for Bernie
because um it included a second video
[Music]
case you're wondering I lost my voice
not cocaine I used to like there's this
third real video where Bernie claims
that cancer is caused by women not
liking sex here you go
I have my own feelings about what causes
cancer a psychosomatic aspect if by the
way you can read his paper on that where
you talk about women who don't like kind
of sex yes yes unrelated news by the way
all women with whom Bernie Sanders has
had sex have died of cancer one person
also by the way a big story for Tex that
has caused record temperatures and I
think this comes from AccuWeather you
know their global warming deniers
temperatures plummeted under 20 below
zero which fighting ones dropping to
under 50 blowing some say so everyone
else knows out there please please do
stay warm thoughts and prayers out there
most affected of course our Americans
across the Upper Midwest who've seen
multiple deaths due to the current polar
vortex and record cold spell least
affected is Ruth Bader Ginsburg so yeah
she's just chillin yeah just hanging out
with a lot but I mean that's awesome not
to get into any current conspiracy
theories because you had enough of that
would anyone be surprised if they bernie
is a week in the brown Bernie Sanders
sir
weekend at Bernie's are weekend's Burke
yeah yeah you're the barefoot already in
your body
it really it really is I mean she's
she's she's probably dead yeah what look
one thing one thing if you if you hate
Donald Trump that's fine but his tweets
are pretty funny when it comes to stuff
like this he's saying like oh god we
need the global warming like bring the
global warming back right because it's
so cold out there
but one other thing why is every severe
weather event evidence of global warming
even when it has nothing to do with you
exactly it's because you do not
understand the fundamental difference
between weather and climate
in other news you know we always comb
through all of the late-night shows
every week so that you guys don't have
to know is looking at Colbert Meyers who
a Kimmel and they're all talking about
this and of course immediately throwing
it on climate change deniers we're not
gonna get into climate change right now
no but they go of course these people
they don't understand the science behind
it well really I notice you had an
animal specialist on with a marsupial
you have a scientist is either Jimmy
Kimmel so why do you get to discuss it
and someone the other neither one of us
are scientists let's use our logic and
Jimmy Kimmel started his career with
like girls jumping on trampolines and
like an old guy that could chuck in a
beer
yeah he's the last person I'm gonna
listen so number two would be myself
here's something by the way that is peak
Canada if that's a term and remember
peak oil I don't think I think what a
generation people who don't remember
that peak oil was a thing turns out it's
not a thing so these Montreal motorists
they were actually stuck in a massive
pileup why because people playing hockey
here you go
[Applause]
look so boring yeah yeah not to be
outdone by the perpetuation of the
original Canadian stereotype by the way
was this moose who joined the Mounted
Police yeah okay while drunk and he was
mounting another Mountie actually while
Prime Minister Trudeau watched so there
is that that's as Canadian as it gets
that's pretty Canadian we people listen
to the audio version that probably makes
no sense at all for people watching it
we apologize profusely
we like the joke I mean this is a comedy
show after all but you could really see
Justin Trudeau actually being someone
who likes to watch yes you can see why
did you have to watch with a ball gag in
his mouth that I understand why wouldn't
he well why would you not oh gosh people
have their own people have their own
proclivities yours is you know that wine
bottle inverted finally maroon 5 by the
way cancelled their news conference to
start a little bit confusing canceled a
news conference on the Super Bowl
halftime show comes from deadline the
move comes amid a backlash against the
group tie defends believing the band
should cancel their performance as a
show of solidarity for Colin Kaepernick
so to be clear it seems like they might
perform or it seemed like that this
morning they canceled their new their
news conference some were concerned and
it seems now increasingly like the band
might actually cancel their performance
outright luckily the Super Bowl has a
plan B
[Music]
in case anyone in this program ever says
that I publicly embarrass them there is
nothing you could possibly do one
I now know a Johnny boy the only thing
more offensive than you in a thong is
the words maroon 5 this makes me want to
support Colin Kaepernick man how did
they get the Super Bowl gig
I don't know actually I don't mind them
I don't love them but I don't hate them
hey by the way the winner of last week's
I think is it hashtag lwc trivia yes the
contest is Ronnie Biggles at big goes
back in here we go I think we have a
screengrab there so he wins what does he
win there broad again he wins a shirt oh
you want a shirt and I believe a drawing
of a mug lays smooth Matty
oh we do this before the show we do
trivia now and some people really know
their trivia address I forgot that
yeah and then you know of course we
alert the FBI and oh yeah all right so I
think this goes back to the question the
day I want to move into I think the
left's really just infanticide yeah
their agenda I think the abortion mask
right now is is slipping it's done yeah
it's gone it's gone much is gone I think
what's important up to in the past and
we've talked about this we did that
video with Abby Johnson former director
of planetary net which was immediately
demonetized surprise seven long-form
discussion god no money at all
no profanity just we don't like your
opinion in the past the Planned
Parenthood message was that the abortion
it only made up about 3% of their
services remember that the recent
BuzzFeed puff piece though on the newest
CEO I think wasn't evenly Leana when
they had headline about Planned
Parenthood focusing on non abortion
services and Leon Owen then contradicted
it corrected them with a tweet claiming
that abortion was quote their core
mission basically just confirming what
we already knew right surprise this guy
is blue this is really important people
to note the safe legal and rare has gone
out the window and if you look at the
pills from we'll get into them in a
second the bills from New York now as
the bill in Virginia and there's is
there six or seven proposed bills in in
Rhode Island Brautigan I think we're up
think it's up to seven okay there are
quite a few and they're just as yet so I
think a few points to keep in context
here Democrats and I mean the DNC
platform let's not talk about well you
didn't want to generalize main another
extreme right no no the DNC the
Democratic platform they are pushing
abortion up until birth don't believe me
here's delegate Kathy Kathy is a trans
man
Kathy Tran talking specifically about
the abortion donor state so the way the
suggestion that we've made in the bill
is to say it's in the third trimester
and at the you know with the
certification of the physician or
perform an abortion if he indicated it
would impair the mental health of the of
the woman good question as a cloth okay
okay I'm talking about the mental health
it's really really so I mean sorry the
third trimester the third trimester goes
all the way up to 40 weeks okay but to
the end of the third trimester I don't
think we have the limit in the bill that
means a baby by the way we're not talk
about a clump of cells we're not talking
as I goats she's saying mentally she
tries to this is what happens right she
tries to redirect it well or physical
health he goes okay but there's also
mental health we agree on physical
health if a mom is going to die at that
point if both beings are going to die
obviously you take the lesser of two
evils in that scenario I understand it
as a reasonable argument I want get into
that right now
but the broader exception is mental
health yeah
what about mental health I'd be like
going in for a mortgage or gonna it's
gonna be a three percent rate do % no no
a second that's not how this works
you're just gonna say a word and she
refuses to say a baby it up until it
comes out of the birth canal yeah it's
like a medicine any reason by the way it
can mean anything mental oh that's like
a medical marijuana card only with
killing a baby yeah I am
that pain I don't like the baby I think
he's gonna be it yeah
approved yeah and that's what people
think like oh my gosh it's gonna be this
refined process no there are doctors out
there that want to be at advocates for
this and activists essentially and
they're gonna do it for whatever reason
right we're gonna see economic health
pretty soon here right that's right
that's the third thing that we're gonna
see I can't afford this it's about two
weeks until the baby's due can you
please help me right
really people say would you really think
it's going to get that extreme well okay
when we went to the next point but
considering that smiling is now seen as
the sign of white supremacy there's like
well you're not supporting the welfare
state that's what you promise you'll go
I don't really think so but okay you
want to use some demographics and say
that it's a discriminatory toward
minorities all right
voting for Donald Trump is racist I
don't really think that's the case
smiling is like the KKK yeah how quickly
do you think it will devolve here on the
left when it comes to abortion I don't
know how much further they can devolve
here this brings us to our next point
Democrats by the way are pushing for
abortion even after birth no that's
murder there will be blood it's no one
here's a new governor Ralph
is it pronounced Northam north ham no no
and basically endorsing infanticide
thank God we videotape radio interviews
now let's play this when we talk about
3rd trimester abortions these are done
with the consent of obviously the mother
with the consent of the physicians more
than one physician by the law and it's
done in cases where there may be severe
deformities there may be a fetus that's
non-viable so in this particular I can
tell you exactly what would happen the
infant would be delivered the infant
would be kept comfortable the infant
would be resuscitated if that's what the
mother and the family desires and the
discussion would ensue between the
physicians and the mother so so I think
this was really blown out of proportion
it was what happened to non-viable yeah
he literally says non-viable the first
happens by the way then we might
necessitate the baby feed it but give it
a feeding make sure that it's alive and
then
leave it to dyes we have a discussion
yeah what kind of a discussion say okay
listen you have a baby right now who's
been swallowing blankets it's in the
next room we'd like to see what kind of
options you'd like to discuss including
our tiny caskets special for only $5.99
on the table you only have half an hour
to act though it really is remarkable to
the north it must've been really
interesting kids if you don't shut up a
discussion will ensue all right listen
I'm gonna turn this car around have a
discussion with you even the Adams
family would look at this and say God on
me that's well if there's the slightest
silver lining in people saying that we
should kill literally kill kill people
if this wakes people up with a pay more
attention to issues because I've noticed
a lot of a lot of a political friends in
New York are expressing their disgust of
the New York bill yeah I'm gonna go on a
limb that their voters in Virginia who
consider themselves to be pro-life but
voted for the governor just because
orange man bad sure hopefully now they
could people are waking up and you know
there are worse things and Donald Trump
being a book on Twitter and it's killing
me oh and that's why I hate the whole
discussion of let's find common ground
let's meet in the middle no hall in a
second this is the National Democratic
platform guys right this isn't some
extremists isn't it the Young Turks this
isn't Samantha bee this is what all of
the Democrats who when they form state
legislature this is what they want this
is what they have and by the way is this
a shock it shouldn't be concern that
Democrats have repeatedly voted against
measures like the born alive into
protection act which protected babies
after they were born alive it's in the
name Barack Obama didn't vote president
he voted no this has been the mo of
those in power for a long time other
ways just they haven't had it completely
unfettered and if you want to know what
it looks like just look at New York yeah
and this could basically single-handedly
give the election over to Donald Trump I
really don't know why this issue is
coming out in force like it is right now
because we're about two years before the
presidential cycle we are sorry about
two years before the election so the
cycle starting yeah people are gonna
start going out you're seeing it with
Democrats saying they're gonna throw
their hats in the ring if this issue is
on the table and that bill I don't get
what they own deaf we pulled this story
from Huffington Post okay and a headline
it was something like Tucker Carlson
gets burned in his own show and he asked
this liberal guest he says okay you saw
this from
from Northern right here yeah what do
you think about this I think you want to
take us back to overturning roe v wade
he goes no I don't want to do that but
can can we not throw out talking points
can you please talk about this which was
on tape today I wanna talk about how you
have no say what women do with their
bodies Huffington Post watch this exact
same video and they see it as a win they
put that one up on the scoreboard for
themselves speaking of wins by the way
hit the notification bell if you're
subscribed because apparently doesn't
mean a whole lot on YouTube and it might
get lost in the subscription box join
Mudd Club nine million dollars annually
six nine for students veterans active
military laterals credit.com slash mug
Club you get the full daily show and
it's what supports the content also
iTunes if you're listening to the audio
version yeah to answer Gerald's question
the reason why it's all coming up now
apparently a lot of Democrats feel that
because Trump is so weak of a candidate
and so disliked this is the
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to put
out all this crazy stuff yeah because
people are just gonna vote not vote for
them a vote against Trump here's what's
also really important enough that
abortion up until birth it's it's not a
far left position I cannot reiterate
that enough this guy he's not Cortez
he's he's seen as a centrist okay the
Virginia bill was defeated but New York
just passed the but the bill is passed
yeah and now I think it's someone can
correct me it's either seven or six
bills proposed in Rhode Island this is
important to know this is mainstream
leftism so when people say oh you know
there's such a stark contrast between
all of these Democratic candidates in
Donald Trump sure you all want to kill
babies up to 40 weeks and after 40 weeks
good there's there's enough of a
contrast and this is the thing for me
right now this is where you draw the
line I know yesterday we were talking a
little bit about some finding some
common ground educating people this is
not that issue necessarily when you
start to say that you're okay with third
trimester you go out of your way to make
it physical health instead of mental
health of this gigantic loophole that
you know people are gonna run through
you have absolutely revealed what your
strategy is and one thing that you don't
want to do people dislike Donald Trump
but they are so pro-life that they will
get out and vote for him here's what's
really important the left is lying in
order to try get this legislation passed
they say well most Americans are
pro-choice
okay we're using the term pro-choice but
the the American public are
overwhelmingly against abortion up until
birth as opposed by 80 percent or so
most Americans don't support third term
sir abortions the Democratic platform
does yeah this is something crazy to me
to present such a big deal out of Trump
insulting people about being notes being
rude or ugly I'm so ashamed in our kids
have to be raised in an area with the
president's so ugly
what's uglier than swaddling a newborn
baby placing it into a crib in the next
room and then discussing whether you
kill it or not name me one thing that
Donald Trump has ever done including
grabbing all of them that would be as
ugly as that story let's stormy Daniels
that's bad okay that's fine I stand
corrected
and you came to the Advocates is
something it's really important it's
just inaccurate this is one of those
issues where the further we advance
scientifically the less ground they have
to stand on they make this claim that
third trimester abortions only necessary
in some rare circumstances when the baby
is gonna die anyway no it's that's not
what's actually happening so good marker
Institute which by the way pro-choice
pro-abortion organization says that the
data shows quote most women seeking
later term abortions are not doing so
for reasons of fetal anomaly or life
endangerment Wow but it's right there
and then I thought I thought we had
medical procedures for this if the
baby's life was in danger if mom's life
was in danger and going to term with
this I thought we had c-sections yeah I
thought that was part of the issue
saying hey this is dangerous let's do
this by the way do you know there's
story after story after story right now
in the media that people who are alive
20 years later saying my the doctor told
my mom I was not viable right and I made
it out fine she's fine
this isn't an exact science for these
guys there's a huge lane to drive I just
for sure so geographically dependent oh
wait a second a baby in the hills of
Virginia not not Virginia with a West
Virginia's gothe West Virginia of
Kentucky right baby is it is that life
worth less than the Navy in a hospital
in Lenox Hill in the upper east side
simply because they've accessed a better
medical viability is not a consistent
argument what's crazy why are we
supposed to find common ground here this
is what's great there's no common ground
left oh ho let's find common ground on
plan B okay let's do it now now how
about second trimester what we're
supposed to find now up until birth if
it's born can we kill it remember common
ground common ground and they want to
call you an extremist safe legal and
rare was supposed to be the common
ground for a long time rape incest
health of the mother that was supposed
to be Congress I just said health how
like
the hill helped Murrah of the mother not
mental health and this is so great
what's so funny to me they said this
have Christians for a long time right
these two say oh there's single-issue
voters they're morons or single-issue
voters if you're gonna be a single issue
voter what's more important hating
Donald Trump because you think he's a
dick or not killing live babies imagine
looking back through history and saying
man the out the Allies in World War two
were really single issue guys Abraham
Lincoln was a single issue
here's the thing yes I understand
obviously the economy matters if you're
looking at election trade whatever but
if there are still people who are being
enslaved against their will then that is
the only issue it's just like if you
cover somebody's mouth and pinch their
nose then all of a sudden you call them
an oxygen extremist issue they're all
the issue that matters that point is
oxygen right and all the single issue
voting was justified we knew it it was
never going to stop at Hobby Lobby
providing what was it they provided 16
out of the 20 or 21 forms of birth
control and they were saying no Hassan
and they have to be mandated to provide
all 21 forms of birth control that was
never going to be the end point the end
point was never going to be the plan
bill Plante Plan B uh pill their plan
was always to push it this far and by
the way how is this not straight up evil
purposefully evil I think that people
can be used as tools of evil I've talked
about Barack Obama with this I don't
think Barack Obama proactively went out
and said I'm going to subvert the cause
of good right I'm an evil person but I
think he was used as a tool for evil
certainly if you look at his voting
record specifically on this issue but
with this it's not someone who's being
used as a tool without knowing it free
they are proactively killing babies they
are walking into the room knowing fully
what their mission is to kill a baby
that's it they don't care and this is
what's so funny we could say like oh
this is one point this is a path to use
in a euthanasia Rite of death of
children but this slippery slope is an
argument there is no more slope there is
no more path we're done we're at the end
of the path that's it here I'm going to
make a bold statement here what Hitler
did is no more evil than this he just
did it more times are you are you saying
that yes yes I believe that aborting a
BAE
at 40 weeks at 25 at 30 at 35 weeks
certainly after it's born I believe that
is every bit as evil as what Hitler did
yeah you think you think that's an
extreme example to make a point it's two
of the biggest states in the Union are
you okay with this you're okay with
babies being born alive dying because
that's where we are now it's that one
okay I'm okay with this but no no hold
on a second we're past all other
considerations there is no more slope
there is no more slide there is no more
path we're here that's the final
question are you pro-life okay or are
you Pro this what's this delivering a
newborn wrapping it in a blankie and
then leaving it to die that's what's
happening that's what's happening right
now
legally that's what the legislation is
pushing for period there's no more path
there's no more slope to slip this is
where we are are you pro-life or are you
Pro this that's it
find common ground on that will have
Nigel Faraj after the break
[Music]
[Music]
Levin vendian if I saw skunk answer me
then vendian Joe Bosso revenge entiendo
Vasso class on cancer even vaguely endow
vassals con cancer me van Vandy endo
battle con cancer the end event van the
endo vasus con cancer even simpler ito
nears algorithm for it some Prairie from
Florence some Prairie tune sobre Rito
[Music]
then melting here Rosa Parks story Clara
considerations told me that too little
water with brother Oscar life started on
February 24th you know at night no no
that's a Sunday there's gotta be a for
hard life for you better tone em you got
less sort of go godless
[Music]
where you get horny the largest online
news show in the world
Real Talk real facts posted by Ana
Kasparian and shank week The Young Turks
live on weekdays 6:00 to 8:00 p.m.
easily if you're not tuning in you're
missing out
[Music]
The Wizard of wit you know him as mr.
brexit we know him as our friend you can
follow him on the Twitter ads Nigel
underscore Faraj he just didn't correct
me but he kind of gave me a lesson and
how you pronounce garage is how you can
say his name mr. Nigel thrush thank you
for being on the show sir
good to be back we're so thrilled to
have you and I know you have a new
podcast out for American audiences
people can check it out at n4 ROG calm
quick question before we get into what's
going on with brexit right now I just
watched brexit the film with Benedict
cumberpatch last night have you seen it
yet if so what are your thoughts
fantastical rubbish it pays out one guy
who was you know a backroom boy is it be
some kind of genius
look it's television it's fun I wouldn't
take you too seriously well and I asked
that because of someone who was raised
in Quebec where we had these referendums
you know about about leaving and most
Americans had no idea what's going on
what's going on there with the
referendum and that guy with the
mustache I get you know what it doesn't
really make a whole lot of sense here in
Quebec it's hard to follow so four
Americans
Rex it is pretty tough to follow what's
this film one thing I will say that I
noticed and tell me who thinks is an
incorrect read on it it's the reason
that brexit happened the kind of
arrogance that assumes that this this
movement could have only been bred and
angst or fear or ignorance that's kind
of the point of view the film was coming
from and never really tried to look at
the opposing viewpoint from sincerity
that's what I got from it well look you
know brexit happened because we had a
referendum the referendum happened
because of me I challenge the
establishment over a long period of time
I turned it into a political movement we
got millions of votes we frightened the
pants of David Cameron the Prime
Minister and they thought do you know
what this awful Farage play we've got to
get rid of it if we have a referendum
it'll be easy because we'll win and
that'll be the end of them and what they
underestimates it isn't the ignorance or
the lack of education of ordinary people
it's the basic feeling they have to want
to be part of a country
we are the United Kingdom I'm English
we've got Scottish people Welsh people
Northern Irish people we don't want to
be governed by a bunch of unpleasant old
men in Brussels who we can't vote for
and can't remove what do you think about
it actually it's quite simple for
Americans to understand you know what
America what America allow a court in
Mexico to decide who could settle in
your country well the answer clearly is
no so take a step back brexit actually
is logical and it's sensible I I think
Nancy Pelosi might disagree with you if
she could hold that court in San
Francisco she'd be like come on come on
oh she brings some people over from
south of the border and they'd be
deciding uh no I think it's a good way
to put it it's just amazing to me that
the filmmakers missed that and this is
why why I think things like brexit
happened things like Donald Trump come
as a surprise to the media and not to
people who are actually doing the voting
okay before we kind of move on to what's
happening today for a lot of Americans
were uninitiated here can you give us a
cliff note timeline we have a lot of new
viewers who probably weren't here the
last time you were on the program cliff
notes what breaks it up until now
exactly transpired because right now I
know a lot of people are finding it's
hard to follow some on your last name
who doesn't get it okay good I'm just at
a taxi-driver London blacked out ten
taxi driver he said to me Oh mr. barrows
tell me what's going on I said well I
hope you might be going to tell me it's
because you know it's two and a half
years old since the boat we've got 57
days to go until breakfast you two
happen and at the moment nothing has
been agreed whatsoever our government
approving themselves to be completely
incapable and I'm getting the feeling
that the UK around the world is looking
a bit like a laughingstock
I don't know that it's looking like a
laughingstock I think it is looking too
many on the outside as sort of an
example of dysfunctional government I
think that's how a lot of Americans are
looking at it they're not necessarily
taking the issue of brexit of
Independence as seriously as they can be
hard to get
through the government just doesn't seem
to be working there that seems to be the
impression here well the trouble is this
you see you talked about it earlier the
media all the media all the mainstream
media think brexit is a huge mistake
so they interview people like Sir
Michael Caine the famous film star yes
and the BBC recently oh well sir Michael
surely you don't still believe in brexit
do you as if you know you you know you
were a naughty boy on a night out you
must have come to your senses and and
the real problem is this our Parliament
our government still two and a half
years old does not respect the brexit
vote they're going through the motions
in implementing it without actually
believing in it and that's the core of
the problem whereas an America whether
you like or dislike the Donald he says
something and he goes out and he tries
to do it and gonna tell you your
democracy despite your 35 day government
shut down and rest of it your democracy
at the moment is in a much better place
than ours yeah I think I think people
take it for granted and I also think
people take for granted sometimes that
your your speeches are often very um
they hit people to their emotional core
even though they're intellectually based
but one that you gave recently to the EU
was about the condescending attitude
toward Theresa May you gave an
impassioned defense of her well let me
ask you this one what why did you do it
why specifically here right now because
this was this was intense well because
you know here we are
withdrawal agreement was put together a
very bad withdrawal agreement that we
may or she made a lot of concessions to
the other side right the agreement got
voted down in Parliament but the biggest
majority ever seen against the
government in the history of our nation
she then goes back and says guys this
needs to be amended this needs to be
changed and rather than saying okay
Theresa let's sit down have a cup of tea
let's talk about this they talked down
to her as if she was a 12 year old
school ciao
you know something even though I've got
a big supporter of our prime minister
she's my prime minister she's the prime
minister of my country and to see her
being talked down to by unelected
bureaucrats in Brussels I think it's
disgusting
so you know we're all a bit like that
aren't we we're all a bit tribal we're
all a bit tribal and if our leader is to
mean by somebody else we rally around
and support them did the BBC cover by
the way these are these comments that
you made of the EU
remarkable so as I speak to you now it's
24 hours on from that speech I made last
I looked it was three point two five
million views on YouTube and rising very
very rapidly at the moment the BBC you
know I prefer to call the Brussels
Broadcasting Corporation fair isle state
broadcaster and what I tell you what
many of your viewers won't know is we
have to pay 150 pounds a year to watch
the BBC right don't we get put in prison
and thus fast yeah it's a fact and thus
far despite the fact I've got millions
watching this and goodness knows what
it'll be for the end of the week our
state broadcaster has decided it's not
worthy of coverage which just about sums
up the problem well isn't it isn't there
some beauty in that that we're just
talking about this yesterday when people
think that this division in America they
go man this is something when you really
need to fix there's there's there's too
big of a chasm on a second this is kind
of an example right here the fact that
people have access to this video to your
speech and can watch it the people have
spoken
three four million plays but the BBC
doesn't cover that does create a bigger
divide that does divide people but
that's not because you gave a speech
that's because the people want to hear
the speech and the elites and power are
not delivering it so do you think it's
division in and of itself a bad thing if
it's the a symptom of actions like this
I wouldn't mind it if I wasn't forced to
fire
but actually though you're right because
if CNN or NBC choose not to have a
proper debate would you know what we can
do in America go to watch Louderback
router I'll get a proper debate so so
there are ways around it but this is an
exceptional case because we're forced to
pay for the BBC and I've checked paying
for the BBC I object to a state
broadcaster giving me biased content you
know it's it's funny because a lot of
Americans when they talk about this they
say oh you know corporate media man I go
holocrons all I can I get it corporate
media I understand outside influences
but what's the alternative
government media and I was raised in
Canada I don't know how familiar you are
with CBC and radio-canada and I don't
remember who it was whether it was the
NDP or Trudeau himself but Aaron Burr
one party promised a hundred million
dollars in grants to CBC if he was if he
was elected and the other problems 150
million I'm pretty sure was Trudeau
promised hundred fifty because he won
yes the great thing is we've now got
social media we've now got we you and I
are doing we've now got also as it means
you know of making up our own minds and
the truth of it is if it wasn't for this
medium Breck's it would never have
happened
Trump would never have happened the new
Italian government would never have
happened so we are now living in a more
liberated age though the worry of course
is the Zuckerberg zand others are now
beginning to make our lives a bit more
difficult there have you uh taken some
hits recently yourself on a personal
level have you seen things like their
pages and your YouTube feed things like
that yes yes I would say on average the
content that I put out is reaching about
25% fewer people hmm yeah so I'd say
that's the hit that I've received
because of the algorithm changes and one
of my great hopes and only America can
sort this out you know the rest of the
world follows but it is Silicon Valley
that leads the way in all of this and my
big hope is that President Trump runs
again in 2020 and he runs with a bill of
rights for social media users making
sure that the Zuckerberg zuv this world
can no longer pretend to be a platform
for all idea
is what in fact then now publishes so
would you like to see them there's some
there's some arguments even among
conservatives here stateside and now you
see Cortez tossing or her hat into the
ring where she's upset because she's
been fact-checked by Washington Post by
the way it's not because Washington Post
is a bastion of conservatism its court
is come on you're going too far around
the bend here would you like to see them
regulated as public utilities I think
we've reached the point and I have a
conservative I'm a free-market here I'm
a Thatcher right I'm a regular I'm of
that vintage right but it seems to me
there come times when to the good of all
of us government has to start a monopoly
type situation or oligopoly type
situation existing in these markets and
just as the banks became too big to fail
back in 2008 the four or five Athene of
a handful of social media providers of
these services have become too big for
us to maintain a proper democratic
debate so the answer is yes something's
got to be done and I've got an instinct
here the Trump is brave drop is not
scared of taking on the big corporate
classes right and I think you're gonna
see in 2020 in the run-up to those
elections a proposal to make sure that
we cannot see conservative content being
banned from the homes of ordinary people
I think I think increasingly that you're
correct you know it's hard for me to go
along that trail because I'm a
conservative and with net neutrality
when people used to say well on a second
we have to make sure that all data is
because there isn't enough competition
among ISPs and we're hauling and they're
actually there's actually a lot more
competition among Internet service
providers not everywhere but across the
country when compared to Facebook Google
Twitter Google of course includes
YouTube I think it's a much more severe
situation and the dishonesty is what's
concerning if they're going to be an
open platform fine if they want to pick
winners and losers behind they've just
got to be an honest about it and I think
even a step before regulating them as
public utilities is to make sure that we
know the rulebook because no one does
six months ago
burg I question him in public he was
insisting we're a platformer all ideas
and I said no you are now censoring and
that means you're now a publisher that
means you should be liable for the
content that is on your platforms now of
course I got no response I think I think
people at Zuckerberg realize they're now
in quite a tight spot I'm optimistic my
changes coming in the next few years it
needs to well I think this really does
lend itself to kind of what you were
discussing earlier I know what you talk
about a lot is the lack of transparency
a good examples we just recently had
Abby Johnson former director of Planned
Parenthood
she was Employee of the Year to Planned
Parenthood now she's written books about
Planned Parenthood about their actual
practices about what services they
provide we sat down with her for 45
minutes to go through the ins and outs
of Planned Parenthood what she used to
do what she does now her charity work
that was deemed monetized and deemed a
violation of YouTube's policies and one
what a second it's one thing to disagree
it's also another thing by the way if
it's nc-17 content I understand that you
have the right to put that in restricted
mode but this is a reasonable long-form
conversation without profanity that is
somehow being throttled and that to me
the only justification I can see in the
left's mind is the same reason they
don't show your speech on the BBC is a
complete lack of transparency because
when there's transparency we win yeah
they effectively become not just the
financial benefactors but they also
become the arbiters of choice and that's
a real problem and that cannot continue
and that is the thing that has to
absolutely change otherwise otherwise
these amazing changes we've seen in the
world since 2016 these Liberation's
of the brexit boat the trunk boat the
Italian boat otherwise it will be
stopped in its tracks because there's no
way that CNN or the BBC are ever going
to give us a fair crack of the wig we
have to create this ourselves we have to
get these messages out and we need
social media by the way we're not asking
for advantage we're just asking for a
level playing field with all reasonable
non-discriminatory non-violent arguments
exactly we were just asking for the same
playing field as Benedict cumberpatch
and I think that's not a whole lot to
ask though he does have eyes in which I
get lost
mr. Faraj Nigel underscore Faraj on
Twitter of course checkup and podcast
thank you so much for being here sir we
love having you on please come back soon
I certainly will thank you hey we're
back after this let us begin our quest
[Music]
greetings America
Hoppa here I just wanted to tell you
that on my eBay profile for sale right
now is a one-dog argentino puppy named
Betty and for the price of the current
offers euro dollars I will pay shipping
all right single library of the week
time first hold on a second have
somebody gonna get upset here let me
check there you go
Walter of course a great sponsor we're
very happy to have them on the show of
course the number one sponsors my club
you can join my club but Walter um this
is actually this is our new code I want
to talk about it's their ppq Allsteel
pbq five-match it's unbelievable here's
the thing this is possibly the best
firing firearm I have ever shot period
but if you're going to buy a one Walter
it wouldn't be this I would get there
ppq first or there PPS or there ppq
subcompact but if you're looking for
something that is out of the box on
scary accurate and easy to shoot and as
sexy as it gets this is the gun for you
the PP q 5 policy I don't know if
they're selling them yet but really a
thankful to Walter of course their
studios are protected by Walter we all
carry Walter's and their the balls to
support the show there are a lot of good
firearms out there we know that all we
ask is that you go to the gun range
try the Walter just give it a shot let
us know what you think the product sell
themselves that like cigarettes thanks
Walter
[Music]
I didn't make it to the end because I
was holding my breath very intelligently
and I have no idea what you know what as
it goes back to trip thank you to Nigel
Farage from the Tribune I don't know
when the drowning dance started I
genuinely have no idea
I think it has something to do with the
fact that it sounded like the original
underwater level music in Mario it
doesn't vaguely sounds like that or like
Sonic the underwater song would be that
doesn't make sense but that that
drowning dance was actually me when I
was a kid where when I went underwater
for the first time I started panicking
because I couldn't move until I realized
I just had to close my fingers so I
thought I was gonna die for sure
I was certain that I was going to die I
wasn't moving and then I closed one hand
you know spun around oh this is loose no
I didn't bust anymore no that was white
that's okay we don't we don't bust moves
when were white Oh young kids young
white kids we don't walk very quickly
compared to black kids we don't bust
moves very quickly compared to black
kids but we're in the pool far earlier
true that makes sense it's 100% crazy
its fact look it up thanks so much to
Nigel for us and I wanted to go back to
something we were talking about abortion
laws in the country and I know that
there are some tweets out there and a
lot of people I guess are more easily
shocked than myself respond to these
stories oh my god how could you how
could you do that to a baby
how can someone go so far I hear that a
lot for many it boggles the mind doesn't
boggle mine and as much as it pains me
to say it I would say it's actually
entirely expected for two reasons one
the same reason I talk about this a lot
in the show up the truth and most
people's aversion to it and to the easy
way out in the - by the way in most
cases are one in the same I often talk
about the truth in the show and how
simple in theory life would be if you're
seeking it and I know that a minute by
the way I know I'm gonna get some edgy
smartass atheist commenting you're say
well the truth would you believe in the
Flying Spaghetti Monster huh okay well
here's a brain twister not all societies
have considered truth to virtue and
certainly not more valuable than
successful outcomes so where is the
morality of truth seeking come from
there's a brain twister same thing with
mercy and compassion those are almost
exclusively found with modern
Christendom they were seen as weaknesses
so truth
seeking is not innate as a matter of
fact often and I would say more often
than not it's the polar opposite of
human nature now keep in mind I'm not
talking about a truth or your truth here
I'm talking about the truth people will
often do whatever they can to avoid it
at all costs like an aunt with a
magnifying glass effectively for the
same reason because here's an irony this
is something a lot of people aren't
gonna like to hear but I'm going to tie
this back to the abortion thing a little
bit and irony is that when it comes to
the truth we've been lied to
we've been told that the truth will set
you free
guess what nope sometimes the truth
comes with shackles sometimes the truth
comes with punishment sometimes the
truth sucks the truth will set you free
okay Your Honor I confess guilty life
without parole
what happened sometimes the truth is
hard but that doesn't change the fact
that it's the right thing to do and that
brings me to point number two the easy
way out I've talked about this before
you can go through the archives there is
almost always an easy way out in life or
at least an easier way out okay and I'm
not talking about by the way the the
most efficient path possible sometimes
the hard road is just wasted energy I
understand that don't get this part
twisted okay what I am talking about in
life is when faced with an uncomfortable
truth isn't it interesting how life
always offers you an open door next to
it almost invariably an easier door
think about it I want you to take some
time here and think about every single
decision that you've made in your life
where you had to stand up or or walk in
truth tell me there wasn't an easier way
tell me there wasn't an opt-out that's
why people kill 40 week old babies
that's how entire state legislatures
smile upon the murder of twenty five
thirty forty week old babies the problem
didn't start with 40 week old babies it
started with plan B it started with the
early term abortions it started with
absolving oneself of responsibility in
turning ones back on the truth okay so
look you screwed up you're irresponsible
you lacked self-control and now you've
brought a life into this world the truth
is you have no right to end that life
let me give you a little bit more leeway
okay let's say you were responsible
every single step of the way you use
protection
okay little tadpole got through for some
reason here you are the truth is that is
still a life an entirely separate
genetic code that cannot speak for
itself and you still have no right to
decide whether it lives or dies the
truth is that it's hard to bring that
baby to term to deliver to take care of
it to figure out what mommy and daddy
need to do how to make a living how to
take care of this life or it's hard even
finding the right adoption program
bringing that baby to term and then
watching them carry it away to another
family who will love and care for it
because you couldn't I get it that's
really hard the truth is hard sometimes
or or you could just take a pill or you
could just put your feet in those
stirrups you could grease the palms of a
doctor and be done with it in an
afternoon now let me clarify here am I
saying that women out there who get
abortions are taking the easy way out
you're damn right I am
absolutely just like I think fathers who
shirk their responsibilities are taking
a coward's backdoor okay I'm not
absolving anyone here but the truth is
hard and there's always an easy way out
and that's why I hate bumper sticker
slogans and false platitudes you really
do hear me try to avoid these on this
show because we use these so often to
lie to ourselves to hide the gritty
truth and to polish a lie right failure
is not an option
my friend shale has talked about this
that's a lie it's always an option it's
often the easiest and most readily
available option you just don't want to
admit the truth that you might fail we
hear this other one all the time I think
we did it in a parody of any given
Sunday with Al Pacino in a fight it's
the guy who's willing to die who's gonna
win that fight it's the guy who's
willing to die he's the one who's gonna
taste victory that's a lie in a fight
it's the person who's best prepared
who's trained with the most discipline
and is the most capable who will win do
you know what we call untrained men who
go into fights her battles willing to
die dead that's the truth but it's a lot
easier to accept a bumper sticker slogan
that's motivating than it is the truth
here's the thing while the truth may not
immediately
you free in the short-term that's a cold
hard truth a lot of people don't want to
acknowledge well the truth may burn
sting or scar it is ultimately the only
path you can walk long term to live your
life as freely as humanly possible and
again before we go I want you to think
of every difficult decision in your life
you've ever made standing up for the
truth
okay I'd really want you to picture in
your mind's eye here okay remember the
easy way out do you remember the other
options available at that time got it
did you look back now look ahead where
do you see the truth where do you see
the easy way out because if you picked
the wrong path now there are only going
to be more and more paths
splitting getting easier and easier
letting you away from the path of truth
and into the permanent shackles created
by the lies of the world that's how you
kill a 40 week old baby you're
pro-choice okay are you paying attention
make the right choice see you next week
[Music]
you